happiness is not a destination happiness
is a direction for somebody to be truly
happy would mean that you would need to
eliminate the parts of your life that
are literally keeping you alive you need
anger and sadness and disgust and and
you need grief and you need all these
things um to stay alive and deal with
the world so pure happiness shouldn't be
the goal but getting happier is a
legitimate goal for everybody the
biggest mistake that people make is
thinking that it's a feeling and chasing
a feeling feelings of Happiness are
really evidence of Happiness sort of the
smell of dinner is the evidence of
dinner it's not dinner itself it'll be a
very disappointing dinner if it were
just you know the smell of Thanksgiving
and it's a terrible thing to live that
way hoping that tomorrow you'll feel a
different way and so the first freeing
thing is that number one don't worry
about being happier let's work on
getting happier it's a project that's
number one and number two is that it's
not a feeling it's something that you
really can work on it's a skill you can
really get better at